why don't we talk about a Chinese rocket
piece screaming over the u.s. that's
actually I'm using that was that was a
that's a quote from another article from
futurism but let's read the news so
here's the story from Popular Mechanics
chunks of China's powerful rocket fall
back to earth narrowly missing NYC it is
the largest piece of space junk to fall
uncontrolled in nearly 30 years yes
since 1991 I guess but check us out this
thing's massive this is why I was like
they say a rocket piece and it's like
what does that mean like a tiny little
rock I know this thing's 20 tons
the tiny rocks would just burn up in the
atmosphere so I mean if it was big but
if it was like stage one and it fell
before escape the atmosphere you know
well I made it all the way across the
entire country and landed in the
Atlantic that doesn't that's crazy
so how did this think that stage 1 I
over the US was the large pour stage of
China's long march 5b rocketry entered
Earth's atmosphere and plummeted out of
control to the surface earlier this week
at a hundred feet long and 16 feet wide
it is the largest piece of space junk to
fall uncontrolled from low Earth orbit
in almost 30 years
huge initial reports suggest that almost
the almost 20 ton rocket stage had
fallen into the Atlantic Ocean off the
west coast of Africa tons 20 tons bro
yeah imagine if that hit in New York new
reports from social media and some
African news organizations suggest
pieces of the rocket may have been
thrown across parts of the Cote d Ivoire
IRA pronounced it I request ivory coast
there you go the heavy lift rocket which
was carrying China's prototype crew
capsule successfully launched from when
Chang launched Center on Hainan Island
off the country's southern coast
typically Rockets have a first stage
that propels them for the first few
minutes after launch while the second
stage helps the payload reach orbit but
long march 5b was different instead the
rocket at a single core stage and four
boosters that propelled it off the
launch pad the speed and angle of the
Rockets decaying orbit made it difficult
to track predictions spanned a range of
sites from New York City to New Zealand
well according to space flight now
that's a pretty large range what yeah
nobody knew what where it was going
that's like if you're gonna if you're
gonna get that prediction you might as
well not predict it at all two different
sides of the planet right right right
seriously where the US Air Force is 18th
space control squadron which tracks
man-made objects in orbit around Earth
confirmed the Rockets re-entry was on
May 11th at around 11:30 3:00 a.m.
initial reports claimed the spacecraft
had plummeted into the ocean off
Africa's West Coast now to village
villages in the Ivory Coast have
reported finding what they believe to be
debris from the fallen rocket stage
according to images posted to social
media and reported in the French
language news organization Africa are
Jonathan McDowell an astronomer at the
harvard-smithsonian Center for
Astrophysics tweeted the location of one
fallen object a nearly 40-foot long pipe
seen in the number of photos Wow is
directly on the cz 5b re-entry tract
look at that oh man imagine getting hit
by that wait hold on I got a question
though it seems like it's it wasn't
close to New York it was it was on the
west coast of Africa how is that perhaps
you take that part yet ok ok so that's a
different part of the rocket yeah yeah
yeah hey hey look they want to claim it
nearly hit New York well there's no
official word on whether these pieces of
debris are actually parts of the Fallen
rocket stage it's looking more and more
likely
latina Zerbo executive secretary of the
comprehensive nuclear-test-ban treaty
organization tweeted May 12th at the
International monitoring systems
infrasound network primarily designed to
detect nuclear blasts in the atmosphere
registered signals of debris traveling
at supersonic speeds in the area what's
the precedent here in 1991 the Soviet
salute seven Space Station tumbled back
to earth breaking up over Argentina the
MIR space station which was
decommissioned in 2001 and broke apart
during a controlled reentry above waters
near Fiji is the largest man-made object
to re-enter Earth's atmosphere and
NASA's Skylab space station famously
pummeled a small Australian town in 1979
if the long march 5b core stage rendered
Earth's atmosphere just 15 minutes
earlier chunks of it very likely could
have fallen across New York City
Ars Technica reported but isn't the
first time China has played fast and
loose with falling rocket parts in March
when China launched its long march 3b
rocket a booster crash-landed downrange
in the grigio province
late last year another long march 3b
rocket ferried two satellites into orbit
but dropped sections of its boosters on
settlements on a settlement near the
launch site in 2018 yet another booster
fell from the sky after the launch of a
long march 3b rocket and exploded just
outside of a small town in the Gwangi
province witnesses posted stunning video
clips of the Fallen booster to social
media in addition to smashing into the
ground with the UMP with unbelievable
force these boosters often still have
traces of the toxic propellant and
propellant hydrazine in them as tempting
as it is if one falls into your heart
yard don't try to get a closer look you
think your yard would exist still if a
20-ton rocket that's insane so they're
saying 15 minutes earlier and it would
have hit New York City
yeah but they just said you know what
man they also said it may say it's
narrowly missing New York City 15
minutes I mean that's all it takes was
New Zealand it's flipping around
oh I mean doesn't the International
Space Station go around the globe in 90
minutes I think so yeah I think they're
flying at like 13,000 miles an hour so
they go around the globe every every 90
minutes I'm pretty sure yeah so it would
make sense I guess make sense so 15
minutes there in Africa 15 minutes
earlier they're hittin New York City my
question though what would have happened
if it hit New York War you think so no
no ma'am I'm sorry a rocket just
decimated one of your biggest cities I
don't think anybody would believe him
that was an accident I think think about
like the damage you could do with an
actual missile yeah but think about how
much more damage you do with giant 100
foot 20 towns slab of steel and very
controllably falling onto her slams into
a building yeah that would just it rails
so many people scary man it would it
would streak across the city Wow man
that would be nuts
it's kind of like remember remember
we're talking about the the tungsten rod
being from satellite yeah like you can
you know you don't need a chemical
explosive you can just we were talking
about this the GI Joe movie I think it
was mm-hmm where the satellite drops the
tungsten rod and just wipes out London
yeah okay I don't think it'll be that
bad but who knows this is something that
we've talked about in the past
like oh yeah when was that GI Joe movie
when did that come out it was a long
time ago yes imagine like what they have
nowadays the tungsten Raj thing has been
like theorized for a long time I guess
of like you know just like firing a high
speed chunk of like very dense metal or
whatever have you seen Westworld I've
seen the first season and parts of the
second season I just finished that no
spoilers here but I just finished the
third season and there's this scene
where one of the main characters was in
the army right and he's doing some some
saying he's like tagging someone with
something he's got like this these
glasses that let him like pinpoint
someone and then he's like yeah target
acquired
hit it and then it cuts to the satellite
and it just you see this missile to
unlock and just go into space and then
drop down out of space and hit this
person and the explosions really small
just the person just haven't you ever
seen the drone strikes and like
Palestine or whatever I mean I haven't
seen these actual videos in videos man
where you'll see you like it's like
black and white grainy footage and
they'll be like a box appear over a guy
yeah and then all sudden you'll see just
like boom and the guy blows up just one
person one person holy cow
hey man look the United States was like
we want to figure out how to kill
somebody and nobody the one personally
the one person I'm very far away we
figured it out doors drones Reaper
missiles hell fireman whatever they're
called yeah yeah so I wonder if if
there's gonna be any anything coming
from this right look I know that we
didn't get hit by it all right but does
this you know does not all Trump then
come out and be like Chinese Rockets
you're very dangerous is there gonna be
a stern talking-to at the very least
yeah or is it like the science community
is like sorry our bad ooh the science
community Ghana's yeah I don't know I
got a bad yeah so so man I wonder we
probably have treaties for this stuff
though yeah probably but I'll tell you
what man you look at what China does you
look at how they how they you know with
climate change with carbon emissions and
like they don't care an Aleutian plastic
waste they don't care they're launching
rockets they don't care no you think
anybody in any
any of these Communist Chinese party
people you know they're probably doing
some guy probably walked in and like I
have a very serious report one of art
you know 20-ton rocket stages almost
crashed in New York and then like some
communist guy starts laughing almost huh
wow that wasn't funny is there anything
on that report that says they would have
hit China no I well why are we why do we
care yeah it's actually interesting
because in this article it says that
they used to like hair li io ahead it
used to hit where it where am I there we
go so they're older ones the three be
somewhere in here it says that and it
was falling and it was falling on China
so they were hitting them they're only
worried about this so they're like man
we gotta up our game and make the five B
rocket because then it'll go into orbit
and we don't have to worry about it
anymore
that's what I'm saying just pointing it
home just point out what I'm saying
allergies are lighting my face on fire
right now just to be completely honest I
am allergies sound terrible oh I'm so
grateful it's not have out yeah we
basically we basically live in a forest
but you know the funny thing you think
like China's hitting itself you didn't
care if they hit us know that no they
were hitting themselves right yeah that
problem that's the thing they're like we
need a 20-ton rocket now and then
they'll get our stuff all the way out
there and then we don't guess so some
guy walked into the the communist party
meetings like we have a serious problem
our rockets keep crash landing on around
cities hmmmm and then they you know got
some calculations and now it's New
Zealand New York and they're like good
job think I gotta promote good work you
gotta read how it's not hitting us but
they're there's more news in the China
front so that the the question about
responsibility is it's an important one
i I know you know we're laughing we're
having a good time like what if this
2010 rocket stage has crashed in New
York killed thousands of people no it's
not funny I mean no China's been doing
messed-up stuff you think about this if
they did something like this
intentionally and then just failing oh
no it was an accident oh yeah well no
we didn't know yeah well what are the
stuff they do know about right yeah they
look at this story what do they know US
officials Chinese hackers are targeting
vaccine research so I have talked about
this before my other channels but look
we've we've got China doing a few things
there's the what I'll use the Simpsons
joke there's subliminal liminal and
superluminal that joke no that's not
like the guy was talking about how they
get people to join the Navy uh-huh and
then Lisa's like superluminal and then
he goes he goes opens the window he goes
hey you join the Navy but that's good
so China hires talent scholars or what I
like talent scout something okay and
they secretly get money from the Chinese
government they lie about it to the feds
they're not supposed to to get this
money and they're not disclosing it to
federal agencies that are paying them so
they're bait so it's basically US tax
dollars funding this research and then
these people are giving that information
to the Chinese government selling it
wouldn't they be technically right right
because they're being paid to be in this
program it's like yeah come on I wonder
when these people are gonna get charged
with treason or something we haven't we
have a cat on the table but let's go to
the wide shot that's that's the super
liminal I mean they're still hiding on
being somewhat silly but then they do
the misinformation where they can still
feign oh oh we didn't do anything wrong
we were just telling our opinions yeah
yeah it's not us and then there's the
overt hacking so that's why look man is
that what this is yeah so they're trying
to they're trying to steal our vaccine
research I mean we know this they're
actually trying to hack us right now
according to US government that's the
trend do I believe it so this doesn't
surprise me at all
actually hey maybe you'll see the cat
he's coming over this so he's trying to
push the cup off the table so what
really kind of surprised me about the
rocket and then launching this rocket
white right now was that they have a
little bit of a pandemic going on there
right now and they are taking out time
to work on a rocket and they're taking
out time to target our vaccinations well
we're working on our rockets ooh we're
about to launch they managed to get one
into space so the timing just caught me
off guard a little bit I was like what
are they doing I mean we're still doing
stuff right true
technically correct we're locked down
yeah we're I mean we're about to send
but like in a week we're gonna send
Americans into space they just weld
people's doors shut you know I mean yeah
it's very fish like hard for us yeah
yeah we had that dang old Constitution
not like these governors are respecting
it or anything but at least Randall
they're well at least we got courts
we're on our side on that so that's on
the side of the people yeah it's crazy
to me it's like I don't know man
I think Rogan was asking me this is like
overtime to society just become
authoritarian like China's so old like
as a culture as a civilization does it
just happen that way
America's young we're young rebellious
like think about it in terms of like an
actual human mmm-hmm you know we're like
teenagers compared to everybody else and
we're like romping around we got guns
and stuff and rockets and we're like
brood oh I gotta think about what about
like Europe I mean granted it was it has
changed a lot over the past 200 years
too you know but they're now you're
right ma'am yeah I'm more about a
nightmare bro yeah
they don't have free speech no they're
like Superman to the extent we do yeah
you're right yeah it just depends on
where in Europe I you're but they're
like very very like you don't think it
is I think I think that's the right
assessment I think what happens is
people defer to safety always yeah
always always so when you get a really
really old civilization they keep saying
it's for your safety over and over again
people just say okay okay and then they
get used to it right so thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you